I 100 believe in extraterrestrials there  is no doubt anyone who doesn't think  that there isn't life somewhere else in  the universe is at this point it's a  really hard argument to make I mean the  data just shows that there are  earth-like planets I I have a sort of a  hard time believing that they're here or  they've been here and they're just kind  of hiding and because in order to do  that you not only have to not blow  yourselves up and become so Advanced  that you can create some sort of  technology that is way ahead of where we  are to create faster than light travel  and then I feel like if you pull that  off and you're going to go all the way  across the universe you're gonna go and  like not hide you're gonna be like what  stop we're here we did it I don't buy  this whole they're they're they're  they're all sneaky why are they sneaky